bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
cetud sport je suis évidemment ravi de
vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
émission passe tout de suite au sommaire
pour sa première saison en pro a et
l'encours est l'équipe surprise du
championnat 5e après quatre journées les
joueuses de franck souliers pourrait
rapidement viser plus haut que le
maintien
page spéciale à suivre avec la réception
d'aubervilliers deuxième du championnat
de nationale 2 de handball montigny
avait l'occasion de se hisser sur le
podium et d'enchaîner pour la première
fois depuis le début de saison une
deuxième victoire consécutive pour le
compte du 3e tour de la coupe
gambardella l'équivalent de la coupe de
france pour les u19 trappe recevait
boulogne billancourt ce dimanche mais
les joueurs de la cbb ont fait respecter
la hiérarchie et évidemment en fin
d'émission l'essentiel des résultats du
week-end mais tout d'abord place à notre
page spéciale tennis de table
je le disais dans les titres c'est la
première saison d'elancourt au plus haut
niveau en pro a de tennis de table et
c'est l'équipe un petit peu surprise de
ce cet exercice ce début d'exercice
2014-2015 cinquième après quatre
journées de championnat les joueuses de
franck souliers réussissant un bon début
de saison et l'entraîneur est présent
sur le plateau du 7-8 sport franck
bonsoir à vous merci d'être là avant de
débriefer plus longuement ce début de
saison il se projeter sur le match de
demain soir
je vous propose de regarder un sujet qui
récapitule un petit peu votre début de
saison avec un montage de romain risque
le but est d'essayer d'aller chercher
des matches nuls ou d'avoir au moins de
ne pas regretter de de passer à côté de
quelque chose quoi donc ce serait
vraiment sympa qu'on puisse bien rentrés
dans le championnat sur les quatre
premières journées par exemple d essayer
d'aller gratter des petits points gauche
à droite quoi ça sert vraiment
intéressant 30 souligné l'entraîneur
d'elancourt ne croyait pas si bien dire
avant le début de la saison après avoir
effleuré l'exploit chez le vice-champion
d'europe lys lannoy en ouverture du
championnat et l'encours a croqué le
kremlin bicêtre à la maison et a ramené
le match nul de quimper désormais
cinquièmes les élans courtoise sont
l'équipe surprise de ce début de saison
pour leur toute première expérience en
proie elle pose des problèmes aux poids
lourds du championnat
une réussite qui trouve peut-être sa
cause à l'extérieur de la table ce sera
très dur de se maintenir en pro a mais
je crois qu'avec de bons matches on se
battant et avec un bon état d'esprit
nous irions daudet le maintien est donc
toujours l'objectif prioritaire du club
mais après la réception de série ce
mardi il se pourrait que les ambitions
soient revus à la hausse
franck comme je le disais dans ce sujet
vos joueuses réalise un super début de
saison oui oui pour l'instant ça se
passe plutôt pas mal enfin quand on a
réussi à pas faire ce qu'on voulait
parce qu'il ya quand même on ne me dit
rien des petites choses à voir quoi mais
au moins on n'a pas pris de retard sur
les équipes qui sont derrière nous qui
pourrait nous embêter pour essayer
d'aller chercher l'objectif du maintien
doit d'ailleurs le classement qui
s'affiche un cinquième après quatre
journées vous auriez signé il ya deux
mois si on vous avait dit vous seriez 5e
vous serez cinquième dans quatre
journées et surtout vous aurez accroché
le kremlin bicêtre à domicile ça c'était
pour nous c'était quand même quelque
chose d'incroyable parce que le le
kremlin ça reste quand même en tennis de
table féminin un club assez historique
parce que déjà chez en france 2013
notamment vice champion de france
l'année dernière donc ça reste quand
même une grosse équipe du championnat
oui on a fait un très bon match sur le
kremlin ça s'est très bien passé tout
juste signaler qu'il leur manquait quand
même une joueuse info ouest mais c'est
toujours une victoire à prendre tout à
fait puis ça fait ça a fait c'était
notre premier match à domicile donc
c'était quand même assez important de
voir un peu comment on allait se
comporter sur un premier match à
domicile
et puis on a réussi à tenir la baraque
quoi donc non très bien bonne bonne
bonne entrée de match aussi moi j'étais
vraiment content c'était aussi qu'audrey
puisse apporter une première victoire à
l'équipe et on croit donc ça c'est quand
même plutôt intéressant pour elle et en
plus cela fait de belle manière parce
que
elle a battu une joueuse encore en
france qui est assez réputé pour être
embêtante à jouer et au delà de salalah
réussi à faire une très bonne entame de
match sur la numéro en fin sur une
gérald zanelli voilà carole point niche
et donc un résultat positif mais vous
disiez quelques regrets c'est vrai qu'on
peut pas oublier les lys lannoy où vous
auriez peut-être pu ramener quelque
chose de mieux du vice champion d'europe
en titre
ouais al islah alice on air on est
revenu on n'était pas trop content assez
bizarrement c'était le premier match de
la saison donc on est allé vraiment pour
découvrir quoi en plus ont joué sur une
équipe qui a été vice championne
d'europe et championne de france la
saison dernière donc c'était quand même
du bon voila voila c'était vraiment du
lourd
un bon baptême de feu pour nous en tout
cas et à l'arrivée quand on est revenu
on s'est dit avec quand même quelque
chose aller grappiller là bas parce que
il ya un match que l'on domine et
compère au 5e set alors que l'on mène
tout le temps dans le cinquième set et
si on gagne ce match là où on est sûr de
faire match nul à l'iss qui aurait été
vraiment un super résultat pour nous et
puis ça aurait permis de mettre en
confiance tout le monde quoi mais est ce
que finalement c'est pas cette défaite
qui a laissé un petit peu de traces qui
est peut-être au final un déclic pour
les matchs qui ont suivi
après ce match là on a quand même pas
mal discuté parce que ben moi j'avais il
y avait un côté un peu déçu quand même
de deux d'avoir perdu 4-2 là bas les
joueuses aussi donc on en a on a quand
même pas mal parlé de ce match là entre
nous et écoute j'ai envie de te dire oui
ça nous a certainement servi parce que
le fait d'avoir discuté assez longtemps
de ce match les filles sont vu qu'il y
avait des choses quand même à corriger
tout de suite et je préfère qu'on les
corrige maintenant que le cas deux
journées de la fin où il va falloir
jamais ouais ouais
et donc voilà non ça ça a été bénéfique
quand même ce qu'est ce qui fait que ça
fonctionne parce qu'en fin de compte
vous n'aviez pas de repères c'est votre
première saison c'est la première saison
dans l'histoire du club à ce niveau en
proa vous découvrirez peut-être chaque
semaine des nouvelles choses qu'est ce
qui fait que ça fonctionne entre les
filles
déjà elle et les fils entendre quand
même toute relativement très très bien
j'arrive à vivre quasiment toutes
ensemble se voit très souvent elles sont
en colloque de temps en temps ensemble
on est tous les jours à la salle
quasiment ensemble donc on arrive à
avoir des liens quand même qu'ils seront
assez assez fort en haut niveau de
l'équipe
ces stages aussi que vous avez fait
comme celui douala rire la salle alors
ça c'était quelque chose qu'on essayait
de mettre en place avec ce club là avec
un père parce que j'ai des bonnes
relations avec le coach de l'équipe de
quimper et ça fait déjà un peu près un
an qu'on essayait de mettre ça en place
et là bas l'occasion s'y prêtait très
très bien parce que on jouait l'un
contre l'autre en championnat
et puis les vacances arrivent et donc ça
permettait aux joueuses de se libérer un
petit peu pour aller s'entraîner et donc
on a mis ça en place
et ça ça bat une semaine comme ça oui ça
ça renforce beaucoup les liens notamment
moi j'ai appris à connaître encore un
peu mieux audrey parce que c'est une
joueuse qui s'entraîne aussi à
l'étranger
réservé un programme d'entraînement qui
est qui est quand même assez lourd et
chargé donc elle est allée sur des le
club sur certaines périodes mais elle
est aussi à l'étranger pour s'entraîner
dans d'autres structures pour bat pour
améliorer son niveau et le fait d'avoir
passé une bonne semaine avec elle ça
encore renforcer les liens et puis ça
nous a permis discuter justement des
matches qu'elle a fait depuis le début
de la saison et ça c'est des très bonnes
choses pour une bonne expérience et
justement peut-être au sein de cette
équipe c'est le mélange d'expériences
avec eva odorova biljana todorovic et
cette jeunesse qui apporte audrey zarif
qui est tout jeune et n'a pas encore 17
ans et puis yanan wang qui aussi à ces
jeunes comme la jeune est complètement
mais met d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se
passe c'est que on a vraiment on a une
équipe qui est composée de joueuses qui
ont énormément d'expérience comme eva
comme il y en a et va surtout parce que
vraiment par rapport à son histoire au
niveau sur le haut niveau en tennis de
table c'est quand même une joueuse qui
qui a quand même un parcours incroyable
évidemment participer aux jeux
olympiques ouais et puis aux
championnats d'europe dernièrement
puisque son son pays
la reconvoquer pour rejouer des
compétitions internationales dont
qu'elle a accepté ce que je crois je
crois qu'elle a vraiment envie de finir
sur les jo de rio donc je pense que sans
la lessive sa dernière grosse
compétition internationale et puis on ad
oui on a la jeunesse quand même une
fille comme comme yann and key qui a 25
ans arrive à ce niveau là découvre
championnat de poids pour elle pour la
première fois de sa vie
oui alors besoin d'apprendre beaucoup
aussi d'ailleurs mais bon voilà ça se
passe bien et vous allez peut-être
continuer d'apprendre demain soir ce
mardi parce qu'il ya cette réception
d'un match face à serris match capital
presque j'ai envie de dire au classement
ils sont 8e c'est un club qui va
sûrement lutter pour le maintien comme
vous s'imposer demain soir et est une
priorité des jeux s'il faudrait pas
perdre ça ça serait vraiment intéressant
de ne pas perdre et maintenant oui nous
on a l'ambition de les battre parce que
effectivement ça fait partie des clubs
avec lequel on va se bagarrer pour se
maintenir dans cette division
je pense que c'est pareil hein ils
veulent venir faire un bon résultat chez
nous
donc oui le match de demain soir est
vraiment important voire très important
et justement si vous voulez aller
supporter les féminines d'elancourt
c'est demain soir au palais des sports à
partir de 19h30 merci beaucoup franck
d'être passés sur le service fort et on
verra évidemment ce match avec beaucoup
d'attention demain soir du côté du
palais des sports
allez sans transition passe haut en bas
avec la réception d'aubervilliers je le
disais dans les titres deuxième du
championnat de nationale 2 montigny
avait l'occasion de se hisser sur le
podium
et d'enchaîner surtout pour la première
fois depuis le début de la saison avec
une deuxième victoire consécutive à
l'arrivée contrat rempli avec des images
de florennes parfait dans les chocs au
sommet c'est souvent dans l'agressivité
que les équipes vont chercher la gagne
mais encore une fois à ce jeu-là montini
a démarré la rencontre face aux
deuxièmes aubervilliers en mode diesel
très vite distancé de trois buts lésigny
monteyne reste à distance grâce à leur
capitaine gabriel par l'ol auteur d'un 4
sur 5 aux jets de 7 m elle rentre aux
vestiaires avec deux unités de retard 15
13 pour aubervilliers
on laisse jouer en fait les finales face
on met pas les attaquer au bon moment et
on se fait prendre sur des mêmes actions
en jeu quinze fois croire et c'est à
nous d'être réactive d'être plus en
puissance sur l'adversaire de prendre le
dessus plutôt que de se laisser marcher
dessus travailler cette semaine à
l'entraînement
l'intensité dans les duels bas enfin
être mises en application par les
inhumant ten après la pause les
saint-quentinoises reprenne les rênes de
la rencontre pour mener 25 22 après 15
minutes de jeu
elle gère ensuite leur avance pour
finalement s'imposer 31 28
elles infligent à leurs adversaires du
soir sa seconde défaite de la saison et
pour la première fois depuis le début du
championnat les joueuses de philippe
étrange enchaîne deux victoires
consécutives
résultat des courses montigny est à
nouveau maître sur son terrain et se
hisse sur le podium de cette poule 2
derrière le havre et aubervilliers très
heureux de la victoire parce ça nommé
dans le haut de tableau et c'était très
difficile
en sachant que les trois premiers
matches on les avait perdus à domicile
donc les filles se sont mis une pression
on a on a retrouvé une montini en
deuxième mi temps énorme première
mi-temps donc c'était un peu compliqué à
la mi-temps alors mis un coup de
pression et défendre l'argument une
belle deuxième mi-temps pour le compte
du 3e tour de la coupe gambardella vous
le savez c'est l'équivalent de la coupe
de france chez les u19 les -19 ans
trappe recevait boulogne billancourt ce
dimanche au stade gilbert chance ac mais
les joueurs de la cbb ont fait respecter
la hiérarchie des divisions compte rendu
réalisé avec claire cambier et florennes
parfait dans le costume du petit poucet
trappe avait l'occasion d'accrocher un
pensionnaire de division d'honneur à son
histoire avec la coupe gambardella
mais au cours d'une première période
très hachée par des temps morts et de
nombreuses imprécisions techniques menés
au score les trappistes ressentent les
deux divisions d'écart avec boulogne
billancourt notamment dans le placement
défensif
le retour des vestiaires c'est le moment
que choisi boulogne pour faire le break
suite au dégagement du gardien
l'attaquant de la cbb efface son
défenseur et croise parfaitement sa
frappe dans le dernier quart d'heure
trappe réduira l'écart au score sur
penalty
mais cela ne suffira pas pour arracher
les prolongations boulogne-billancourt
s'impose 2 1 et se qualifie pour le
quatrième tour à gilbert source ac
la logique a donc été respectée dans le
genre on a été bon aujourd'hui
donc après c'est face à une équipe de dh
donc ça joue sur de petits détails
donc on n'a pas encore cette
expérience-là de dh donc on avait près
ce qu'il fallait prendre aujourd'hui et
après ce 3e tour de coupe gambardella
vous allez le voir le bilan yvelinois
est bien maigre maurepas s'est incliné
face à aubervilliers de but à zéro
versailles père à ivry 2 1 et cela ne
passe pas non plus pour montigny étrillé
à evry 6 buts à un seul rescapé
yvelinois poissy et conflans sainte
honorine
pendant quatre jours l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines a accueilli la
12e édition de l'opération sport ans
filles automne cet événement permet de
promouvoir le sport féminin
car en ile de france les filles
représentent à l'heure actuelle appelle
33 % des licenciés de clubs toutes
disciplines confondues et -2 25% dans
les quartiers dits sensibles sport en
fille et ouvert évidemment jeune fille
issus de quartiers populaires de toute
l'ile-de-france au total pendant quatre
jours près de 400 adolescents âgés de 12
à 17 ans découverte de nombreuses
disciplines dites sport nature comme la
randonnée pédestre ou encore la course
d'orientation et le roller skate y
reprendre goût à l'activité à la
motricité par la rencontre aussi de lien
social parce qu'on compte aussi beaucoup
sur la rencontre entre les offres les
structures entre les jeunes filles qui
sont pas toujours même justement de se
rencontrer les unes avec les autres et
puis par derrière effectivement de
pouvoir avoir une pratique régulière
encadré effectivement aujourd'hui nous
avons nous professionnels qui sont
envoyées par les ligues et comités
régionaux de l'île de france et qui sont
là pour justement leur faire découvrir
le sport
donnez leur passion et puis les
effectivement les et les inciter à
reprendre
en pratique régulière pour pour leur
futur leur futur et surtout leur
adolescence allez on passe au journal
des résultats du week-end et en football
ce week-end avait lieu le 6e tour de la
coupe de france et il restait deux club
yvelinois encore en lice mais
malheureusement aucun n'a survécu
conflent s'incline face à la cfa 2 de
noisy le sec 1 à 0 et de son côté chatou
n'a rien pu faire face à champigny
pensionnaire de dsr revers 3 à 0 chez
les femmes
5e journée de division d'honneur
montigny a bien réagi après sa défaite
chez le leader saint denis la semaine
passée les ignames antennes se sont
imposés à domicile face au puc 3 buts à
2 et vous allez le voir au classement
cette victoire permet à montigny de
gagner une place et se retrouve deuxième
avec 13 points à une petite longueur du
leader saint denis là que la bataille
pour le leadership risque d'être très
compliqué jusqu'à la fin de saison en
rugby sixième journée de fédérale 2 et
autant de défaites malheureusement pour
plaisir cette fois ci le père s'est
incliné sur la pelouse d'angers 48 à 5
nouvelle défaite très sévère et vous
allez le voir au classement toujours
sans la moindre victoire les plaisirs
war reste dixième et dernier avec zéro
point au compteur sauf miracle la
relégation du prc ne semble plus faire
aucun doute
basket féminin au programme ce week-end
pour le compte de la 6e journée de
nationale 2 poursuivi par les blessures
l'an tank de chesnay versailles est
passé tout près de son premier succès à
saumur une défaite de 10 points 55 à 45
mais des progrès dans le jeu a noté au
classement évidemment le fcv restent
scotchés dans les profondeurs de sa
poule de n2 à la 11e place avec 6 petits
points à six longueurs de la glacerie
chez les hommes nationale 3 fortune
identique pour le fcv qui n'est jamais
passé aussi proche il faut le dire de sa
première victoire cette saison en
s'inclinant face au mans 66 à 62 de ce
côté trap a cartonné barjouville sur le
score fleuve de 91 à 74 au classement
vous allez le voir les trappistes gagne
une place et sont désormais sixièmes
avec 10 points à deux longueurs du
leader gennevilliers et de son côté le
fcv pointe désormais au
10e rang avec 6 petits points place à
l'agenda du week-end pour terminer ce
set 8 sport et surtout de la semaine en
fait puisque deux dates à retenir et à
ne pas rater tout d'abord du tennis de
table on en parlait avec france franck
saulnier tout à l'heure si vous voulez
aller soutenir les féminines d'elancourt
face aux huitièmes serris de pro à
rendez vous ce mardi soir au palais des
sports d'el en cours à partir de 19h30
il y aura du football au programme ce
week-end cinquième journée de promotion
d'honneur trappe reçoit parisy des
trappistes qui n'ont plus connu la
victoire en championnat depuis un mois
et demi et la première journée ça
commence à faire long coup d'envoi à 15
heures ce dimanche de novembre à gilbert
chance ac c'est la fin de ce set 8 ports
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve lundi prochain un même
lieu même heure d'ici là excellente
soirée sur tv